[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning today
the federal trial of r kelly in new york
enters its seventh day the r b star
faces racketeering and other charges
related to alleged illegal sexual
activity with women and underage
teenagers now this week a former
girlfriend told the court that kelly
brainwashed her and others we spoke to
her back in 2019 and at the time
she did not consider herself a victim
and she defended r kelly
now she says their relationship was
abusive and is testifying anonymously as
jane tarika duncan has been following
the trial erika good morning to you good
morning and not surprising to hear right
that she changed her story because we
heard that from the first witness as
well but in court jane described kelly
as controlling saying he restricted her
tv viewing and punished her if she acted
outside of his rules because she is
testifying anonymously as a victim we
have decided not to air the video of the
interview she did with us for cbs this
morning
you guys don't know the truth you guys
i believe in some
facade that our parents are saying
this is all lies for money that is audio
from the 2019 interview with cbs news
are you happy
where jane now says she was not telling
the truth kelly was at the interview but
off camera jane told jurors the
disgraced singer would cough to let her
know he was in the room
at the time of the interview jane
described a healthy relationship with
kelly whose first name is robert she
also did not consider herself a victim
i'm happy doing what i'm doing i haven't
figured out what i want to do with my
life but i know when that time comes we
know rob is going to support us
regardless right but now she says their
relationship was abusive she told the
court she met and began having sex with
him when she was in high school and she
testified that she was beaten during her
five-year relationship with kelly
similar allegations against the now
54-year-old go back many years but
gained worldwide attention after the
2019 documentary series surviving r
kelly either you're not getting food or
you took a beating
jane says kelly told her the series was
filled with lies and he didn't allow her
to watch it federal prosecutors claim
the r b singer ran a criminal enterprise
involving the sex trafficking of women
and underage girls kelly has pleaded not
guilty to all charges have you ever had
sex with anyone under the age of seven
no
never no
kelly maintains he did nothing wrong he
told gil king that in 2019 and he's
obviously
staying with that uh through his defense
he absolutely has to he's looking at
mandatory minimum sentences that are
huge amounts of time priya supori is an
attorney with several years of
experience in crimes against children
you've heard from jane for example
establishing that
yes they traveled across state lines yes
they were coerced and unable to leave
yes they were in fear of their lives
that is a tough place for
defense counsel and four defendant to be
kelly faces 10 years to life in prison
if convicted on all counts in this case
he also has criminal cases pending in
illinois and minnesota again he denies
all allegations against him and someone
that uh people have been wondering if
we're gonna hear from is the other woman
that you interviewed joycelyn savage her
parents have been in the courtroom but
it's unclear about where she is and sort
of where she stands yeah it's very
interesting to me to hear what what jane
is now saying because after that
interview her parents reached out and
said that's not the daughter they raised
they said too at that time she was
abused and she was brainwashed they said
that back at the time that their
daughter was not telling the truth to me
at the time so it is interesting to hear
her reverse her story but i'm not so
surprised and also about the coughing
there was very loud coughing in the room
tarika but i didn't know r kelly was in
the room i was told he had left so he
was around a corner but he was there the
whole time yeah i don't know what he
sounds like when he coughs but there was
a very loud coughing and to be honest
with you i thought it was a crew person
like what what why are they doing that
right yeah because it was around the
corner i did not know that was them
clearly they would know what that
sounded like but i did not know he was
still in the room and we were talking to
the young women tarika thank you it's
interesting